I'm namely Bravo for raisin TV and today
fast-food workers and approximately a
hundred cities have reportedly gone on
strike demanding higher wages and yet
here in New York City it seems to be
business as usual at every fast-food
restaurant we've dropped by the strike
seems to consist of a roving band of
approximately 150 people going from
restaurant to restaurant where would you
be working if you weren't working for a
fast-food chain
I don't know because I didn't survive in
my education so you know these are the
only jobs that will quote-unquote let
you you know being the low-wage jobs and
have you know minimum education what do
you think one of the main reasons is
that they're fast food jobs are easier
to get well because they don't they
don't require like much experience much
like expertise how did you get your job
actually when I just came from Jamaica I
went to a Burger King on Flatbush flat
was an album or I went to the general
manager thought would talk with it you
paid by the union's to be here we have a
fast food fund that you know fellow
workers put into that fund to support
each other so you know again we're here
to support each other and we're here to
you know say we're standing up for 15
and a union so I mean it's it's all okay
a station
the protest is wrapping up here in a
small park in lower Manhattan at a
certain point during the rally the event
organizers began to block every attempt
about to interview the participants you
said that you were from fast-food
forward what is your name and why are
you following us around so you're gonna
go everywhere that I'm going well we're
going this way you're gonna you're gonna
come sir I'm gonna be this guy you
better get there first